Bella Hadid just posted the most insane  looking sandwich and I think I need to  try it so we're gonna try to get through  it as fast as we can olive oil balsamic  lays dried oregano pinch of chili flakes  dried basil Pepper and a little salt  we're gonna mix that up  so the next step is the Mayo  now she uses fresh minced basil in this  but my instacart shopper got me dried  she adds some like lemon juice to that  with the kind of pickled peppers and she  like presses them into the bottom of the  bun she adds some red wine vinegar to  the lettuce we add the dressing to the  lettuce we do some of the aioli  lettuce on this side  provolone cheese salami shaved turkey  breast some Tomatoes Drew us with that  on top nice who knew that Bella Hadid  was such a sandwich artist  Bella I approve